so we're going to talk about a problem
in geometry and it's called the moving
sofa problem so the problem is inspired
by the real-life problem of moving
furniture around
it's called named after sofas but it can
be anything really you have a piece of
furniture you're carrying down a
corridor in your house or down some
whatever place and you need to navigate
some obstacles so one of the simple
situations and capturing that would be
when you have a turn right turn in a
corridor you need to move the sofa
around we're modeling this in two
dimensions so let's say sophix so heavy
you can't even lift it up you can only
push it around on the floor obviously
some sofas will fit around the corner
some will not and people started asking
themselves at some point what is the
largest sofa you can move around the
corner so that's the question what is
the sofa of largest area large area not
longer store not long is not heavier
just largest area okay not most
comfortable so here's an example of a
one of the most simple sofas you can
imagine so it has a semicircular shape
and we push it down the corridor so
let's see what happens we push it until
it meets the opposite wall and now we
rotate it and of course because it's a
semicircle it can rotate just perfectly
and now it's in the other corridor so
you can push it forward and what's the
area about one lacks adequate area first
of all we have to say that we choose
units where the width of the corridor is
one unit let's say one meter or
something like that then the semicircle
have radius one so I'm sure all your
viewers know that the area would be PI
over two because that's the area of a
semicircle in radius 1 now whether
that's good or not that's that's up to
you it's not the best that you can do
for sure but it is what it is so the
next one that I have here looks like
this so it's still a fairly simple
geometric shape and it was proposed by
British mathematician named john
hammersley in 1968 by the way I should
mention that the problem was first asked
in 1966 by a mathematician named Leo
Moser let's first of all check that it
works and then I'll explain to you why
it work and so you see you can push it
and again it meets the wall and now we
start rotating it but while you're
rotating it you're also pushing it so
you're doing like this and it works
perfectly now the idea behind this
Hamersley sofa is you go back to the
previous one which is the set the
semi-circular one and you should imagine
cutting up this semicircle into two
pieces which are both quarter circles
and then pulling them apart and then
there's a gap between them and you fill
up this gap now in order to make it work
so that you can move it around the
corner
you have to carve out a hole because
that's what you need to do the rotation
part and hammers we notice and this is a
very simple geometric observation is
that if the hole is semi circular in
shape then everything will work the way
it should and so she can move around the
corner and he also optimized the
particular parameters associated with
how far apart you want to push the two
quarter circles and so on and then you
work out the area of the overall area of
the sofa and it comes out to two pi over
two plus two over pi so slightly more
exotic number definitely an improvement
right well that wasn't the end of the
story as it turns out Hammersley wasn't
sure if he'd socially optimal or not he
thought it might be people shortly
afterwards notice that it's not and only
twenty something years later somebody
came up with something that is better
it's not really dramatically better
because the area is only slightly bigger
but eclis more clever I would say so
this is a construction that was
discovered later in 92 and it is it
looks very similar to the sofa that
Hammersley proposed but it's not
identical
so it's subtly different from it well
here you see this curve is a semicircle
right here we're doing something a bit
more sophisticated so you see we've
polished off a little bit of the sharp
edge here and also this curve is no
longer semicircle it's something
mathematically more complicated to
describe and this this curve on the
outside here is no longer a quarter
circle in fact it's it's a curve that is
made up by gluing together several
different mathematical curves so this
shape is quite elaborate to describe the
boundary of it is made up of eighteen
different curves that are glued together
in a very precise way oh and well let's
see it in action
yeah okay so we put it here we push it
and you see I mean it looks roughly the
same as what happens with Hamersley so
far except the small difference here is
that you have a gap now because we've
carved off this piece so there's a
little bit of wiggle room here
you can push it in several different
ways there's no unique path to push it
but anyway if you push it you see that
it works just the same as before by the
way this was found by a guy named Gerber
Joseph perverts mathematician from
Rutgers University the area of his OVA
is 2.2 195 roughly so about half a
percent bigger than hammers Lee's sofa
very small improvement but like I said
mathematically it's a lot more
interesting because the way he derived
it was sort of by thinking more
carefully about what it would mean for
sofa to have the largest area it's not
just an arbitrary construction it's
something that was carefully thought out
and you know leads to some very
interesting equations that he solved and
he conjectured that that this sofa is
the optimal one the one that has the
largest area and that is still not
proved or disproved so that's that's the
open problem here did he conjecture
based on anything of rigor or was it
just he came up with so he's affected
he's fond of his design well it could be
that he's fond of his own I have no
doubt nobody has some roots some some
pretty good reasons to conjecture that
it's optimal because like I said the way
it was derived is by thinking what would
it mean for sofa to be optimal in
particular it would have to be locally
optimal meaning you can't make a small
perturbation to the shape like near some
specific set of points that would
increase the area so I mean that's a
typical approach in calculus when you're
trying to maximize the function than to
find Mac the global maximum you often
start by looking for the local maximum
right so that's kind of the reasoning
that guided him you could say that the
sofa satisfies a condition that is a
necessary condition to to be optimal so
and it's the only software that has been
found that satisfies to this necessary
condition so that's pretty good
indication that it might be optimal I
mean of course you know our imagination
is limited maybe we just haven't been
clever enough and haven't been able to
find something that works better but
that's the best we can do so recently I
am myself became interested in this
problem more as a hobby than as some
kind of official research project I
start tinkering with it and trying to
wrap my head around some of the math
that goes into it which is surprisingly
in trick
but interestingly I was able to find
some new advances in sofa technology you
could say I did several things the first
thing I tried to do is to get a good
understanding what Gerber had done
because it really wasn't obvious I mean
I was reading his paper and it's kind of
pretty technical and dance what can I do
next I mean how can I improve and what
he had done and of course to do obvious
choices would be to try to find a better
sofa than he did or to try to prove that
you cannot find a better sofa and sadly
I was unable to do either of those
things so that was a bit discouraging
but then I had an interesting idea to do
something that is essentially a
variation of what he had done if we go
back to the screen with the the house
with the two corridors right now imagine
that your house has a slightly more
complicated structure to it
what if it looks like this so you have a
corridor and then a turn and then
another corridor and then another turn
and another corridor let's see what
happens when we try to put I mean even
the simplest one of these sofas through
this corridor right so we push it on
through here we rotate it we push it on
through here and now we get stuck
because this is the sofa that can only
rotate to the right now of course when
you have it in your room and you were
sitting only that's not really it
doesn't bother you but for the purpose
of transporting it that can be a
nuisance right so then I asked myself
the question that is the natural variant
or generalization of the original
problem and actually turned out of this
was the version of the problem that had
been thought about by other people as
well and I refer to it as the
ambidextrous moving sofa problem so this
is to consider all sofa shapes that can
move around this corridor meaning so
they can turn in both directions and out
of that class of sofas to find the one
that has the largest area that you're
looking for the optimal anti-terror and
contain the film Zoolander I'm not an
amateur
the problem I have sometimes a baby
can't turn that well then I ended up
finding actually a new shape that that
satisfies this condition of being able
to turn in both directions it no longer
looks very much like a realistic sofa
but mathematically of course it's a
well-defined shape it's perfectly good
okay so you push it you rotate it while
pushing it and it works and of course
it's going to work equally well in the
other direction because it's symmetric
so it doesn't distinguish electrum right
[Music]
there if you didn't that was the same
thing I know I turned left quite subtle
in fact it's subtle in many of the same
way the gerber sofa is subtle so if you
remember I told you that to describe
Gerber's so fly you need 18 different
curves I mean there's three of them are
but that are just straight line segments
but the other 15 are just are curved and
in a few of them are circular arcs so
that's not very complicated but the
other ones are really pretty pretty
complicated to describe curved you can
write down formulas for them and
everything except there's some numerical
constants that are involved that you
can't write formulas for because they're
sort of they are obtained numerically by
solving certain equations now with the
new sofa that I discovered and I did
that by applying the same idea that
Gerber had developed and that I sort of
developed slightly further was led to in
a certain system of equations that I had
to solve and I solved it and that's
where the shape comes from and again it
turns out the shape is made of 18
different curves that you need to glue
together in a very precise way so yes it
is definitely quite elaborate it's not
like it's not a circle it's not a square
it's something new it seems to have one
pointy ends the anything pointed the
ends are pointed yes they meet at a
certain angle and that angle is an
interesting numerical content that also
shows up in the analysis what's the
angle something like sixteen point six
degrees and but more interestingly it
has the precise formula that I can write
down for you and this is another big
surprise that I had when I found this
with like I said with Gerber so far it
you can describe it I mean there's a
full description of what Gerber sofa is
but in math we like to distinguish
between things that can be written in
closed form and things that can't be
written in closed form so a number like
square root of 2 is a number that you
can write in closed form right of course
that's just shorthand for saying it
solves the equation x squared equals 2
but there are numbers that come from
solving like a system of maybe two or
three equations and there isn't a simple
way to say this number is the arc cosine
of
thing or it's PI over 18 or something
like that so it's not easily expressible
in terms of known constant and that's
the feature that governs sofa has is
that to describe it properly you need to
put in certain numerical constants that
that cannot be written in closed form
whereas when I found my new shape I
discovered that it can be written in
closed form in fact all the equations
that describe it or algebraic equations
not not something I was expecting at all
and makes everything in some sense nicer
a Skirvin cipher is thought possibly
today the optimal solution is your
optimal solution here for the ambi
Turner yes proven to be optimal or you
don't know no I don't know so the state
of affairs is precisely the same as with
the original problem namely that nothing
is proved about what shape is optimal
but I derive the shape that is a good
candidate to be the optimal I mean I'm
not going on record as you saying this
is a conjecture of mine because I don't
feel confident enough to make such a
conjecture but certainly it would be a
very plausible candidate and if somebody
were to come and show that of people
they wouldn't surprise me in the least
and if they show it wasn't optimal then
that would surprise me a little bit okay
that's that's a good question because
there's a bit of a story there and so
what happened was that I was playing
with this problem for several months
actually as a little bit of the hobby
that something served not to do with
with my normal research and had more to
do with my hobby of 3d printing